beautiful but bitterly cold
central scotland bathed in sunshine
under a blanket of snow
in the highlands the drifts were several
feet high
after the coldest night of the winter so
far in the uk
minus 16.7 degrees recorded in
atnahara across large parts of eastern
england the snow continued to fall
causing disruption with some vaccination
centers forced to close
but for people missing the alps this
winter it was a chance to hit the slopes
a little closer to home
this field in bishop stortford and
street in glasgow
and a park in edinburgh providing
perfect wintry conditions
but with ambulances struggling to get
through air ambulances were battling the
elements
this one was filmed landing in a garden
in london
[Music]
the weather this month continues a run
of extremes
two years ago the uk recorded its
warmest february day
while last february was the wettest
since records began
this year cold is the theme across the
uk temperatures have struggled to get
much above freezing
even during the daytime and an icy wind
makes it feel even colder gritters have
been working hard to keep the roads safe
as temperatures are forecast to dip even
further
we are putting a lot of air in from the
surface of the area it's causing very
cold temperatures overnight you do get a
lot of ice forming
black ice in particular we need to get
out on the roads put the salt down
make sure safer people drive around in
the morning although the weekend could
be a little warmer
this cold snap is set to get even
chillier before then
becky johnson sky news